I I kind of want to get back to the
basketball a little bit man uh who was
the hardest player that you had to
defend where you just knew that night
was just [ __ ] I I this is who I got to
get on
Zach Randolph oh Zebo
and he was he was [ __ ] it's a beast
and he wouldn't he won't stop and he's
like I don't think people understand
like zebo's like he's like built like a
house how good he was so it was pound
pound pound pound Pound and he gonna
finish him yeah finesse then pound pound
Pound even like back to the Blazers days
he was good and all game long till he
coming with it um
and whatever his team whatever team he
owned his team is they like looking to
go to him like he probably he's like the
leader yeah yeah offensively did you
guys ever get high together like on weed
because I know he's a big pot smoking uh
I think my Zebo be blowing down them
tree well [ __ ] he got hit in Sacramento
with like five pounds of weed or
something yeah my trip who else what's
up with rappers traveling with pounds of
weed or not rappers uh Royal players
want to be rappers rappers want to be
ball players it's always been that huh
yeah did you ever try to have a go at
rapping I got my 16 on my podcast you
ain't here I mean I saw the freestyle
that you put out like that was viral
like 10 years ago no oh no yeah that was
a high freestyle
yeah but this one I did I did it for my
podcast
it's below 16 on it it's cool
when you were did you like uh obviously
being from Jamaica I mean home of 50.
and lost boys too hey yo shout out R.I.P
to free guitar yeah um yeah Mr Cheeks
man damn Love The Lost Boys
uh what was there because you got
drafted in 99 so that's about the time
well Lost Boys was popping and I feel
like how to uh how to rob might have
been in that same time window 2000 2001.
yeah like did you and 50 ever have a
relationship being from the same place
no I mean um me and cheeks me and cheeks
do though that's dope man
shout out to to to the Lost Boy shout
out to Mr Cheeks man nice camera action
God damn it
um okay so we the hardest player to
guard was Zach Randolph what about
uh
the dirtiest player and I don't mean
dirty in like a bad way I mean like you
know there's dirty players no Zach
Randolph he was a good dirty yeah
there's every every possession